das ist eine sagen wir mal
außerordentlich idee planet 9 ein
schwarzes loch was wären die
konsequenzen für die suche nach planeten
wenn es tatsächlich kein planet sondern
ein schwarzes loch wäre klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinieren die wissenschaft videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen es
gibt kaum ein thema das die astronomie
mehr beschäftigt und die emotionen höher
schlagen lässt seit fast fünf jahren
wird planeten gesucht gibt es planet 9
oder nicht oder ist der etwas ganz
anderes eine these werden darüber
berichtet einen ring aus abertausenden
objekten die zusammen die bis zu 10
fache erdmasse hätten hätte zusammen den
gleichen effekt auf die umlaufbahnen
zahlreicher transnet teenager objekte
also kannst du ihn und zwergplaneten wie
ein einzelner planet hmm das sagt die
studie von jihad oma von der american
university of beirut und anthrax sehr
viel jahren von der university of
cambridge aus planet 9 also nur ein
haufen steine oder eben doch ein planet
michael braun und konstantin platte
gehen vom california institute of
technology caltech haben tausende
computer modelle durchgerechnet und
bestätigt dass planet 9 innen doch
existieren könnte auch das hatten wir
schon mal als video für sie stehen die
chancen für planet 95 102 1 er wäre
demnach 400 astronomische einheiten von
der sonne entfernt astronomische
einheiten sind der abstand zwischen
sonne und erde und er wäre bis zu fünf
mal größer als die erde und damit wäre
er höchstwahrscheinlich kein gasplanet
sondern eine super erde baut theoretisch
könnten wir dann irgendwann mal zu ihm
fliegen und auch im landen wobei das
eintreten eines planeten mit einer
solchen gravitation nur mit exoskelett
möglich wäre so aber jetzt das ist eine
vollkommen neue idee was wäre wenn
planet 9 kein planet sondern ein kleines
schwarzes loch wäre james unwin von der
university of illinois und jakob scholz
von der durham university haben diese
these jetzt aufgestellt und das würde
wieder alles auf den kopf stellen
denn dann müsste ganz anders gesucht
werden bisher versucht plan nicht neu
erst mal auf grund der bewegungs
anomalien der transnistrischen objekte
einzukreisen dann muss mit den
unterschiedlichsten methoden wie zum
beispiel die licht bildung von sternen
die hinter dem vorbeifliegenden planeten
liegen und so weiter gesucht werden doch
die wissenschaftler sagen es müsste bei
einem schwarzen loch ganz anders gesucht
werden sie vermuten eine wolke von
dunkler materie um das loch die riesig
sein könnte materie und die dunkle
materie würden in diesem bereich
wechselwirken und das schwarze loch
verraten insbesondere das strahlen
blitze könnten entstehen und diese
könnten gemessen werden es könnten also
ganz anderen methoden genutzt werden
wenn planet 9
ein schwarzes loch wäre die
wissenschaftler wollen jetzt die daten
des fermi weltraumteleskops genau danach
untersuchen
denn das ist eine inzwischen immer öfter
verwendete methode trainiere eine
künstliche intelligenz und lasst sie in
alten daten suchen bei fermi liegen
immerhin daten seit mehr als zehn jahren
vor
die künstliche intelligenz soll jetzt
nach gamma blitzen suchen die sich mit
einer nahezu konstanten geschwindigkeit
über den himmel bewegen allerdings sind
sich die wissenschaftler höchst unsicher
ob sie erfolg haben sollten
beziehungsweise auch planet 9 ein
schwarzes loch ist sie wollen allerdings
die astronomie gemeinde dazu bewegen bei
der suche kreativer zu sein und mehr
möglichkeiten in betracht zu ziehen
james an wenn dazu zum magazin gizmodo
indem sie sich schlicht auf das konzept
eines planeten konzentrieren schenken
sie die experimentelle suche ein sobald
man anfängt über exotischere objekte
nachzudenken wie etwa über primo die
aale schwarze löcher denkt man anders
wir befürworten das nicht nur im
sichtbaren licht nach ihnen gesucht wird
sondern auch in der gammastrahlung oder
in kosmischer strahlung was passiert in
einem schwarzen loch anklicken anschauen
und doktor watson abonnieren supercooler
kanal bis dann bleibt dran